[Music]
I like milk for all the good healthy
things that are in Mankind's most nearly
perfect food good fresh healthy milk the
year is 1981. Raiders of the Lost Ark is
the number one movie and everyone is
wearing leg warmers you've got this
former actor turned politician who's now
the president and he loves free markets
and he has a big problem it wasn't the
national debt or some big foreign policy
issue though he had plenty of those his
problem was too much cheese
the government was sitting on this giant
stockpile of processed cheese that was
in some cave in Kansas hundreds of
millions of pounds and it was starting
to turn kind of gross we've got 60
million of these we can't find a market
for there was so much cheese that one
official said that the best thing to do
would be to dump it in the ocean So
Reagan decides to give it away for free
to America's poor the cheese was to come
out of the caves and into the American
welfare system the great cheese giveaway
began today in California needy people
lined up to get the Surplus cheap as the
cheese flowed to the underserved it
became a symbol of the welfare
experience and soon government cheese
was cropping up in movies and Hip-Hop
lyrics by artists who grew up on the
stuff after that government cheese we
eating steak like powder milk cheese
what else is a thug to do when you eat
cheese from the government by the way
I'm not allowed to actually play much of
those songs because there's like a
copyright infringement if I do and even
though it's fair use they probably will
flag me and I won't make any money off
this video so we left a giant playlist
of all the government cheese songs in
the sources sorry okay but how did we
end up with a surplus of literal caves
full of Highly processed cheese in the
first place and while we're at it why
did I drink so much milk as a kid like
why were there like five of these in my
refrigerator at all times my mom would
give me a big glass of milk in the
morning and then I would go to school
and be served a carton of this stuff
while also reading the best-selling kids
novel at the time which was about a
girl's face on a milk carton and then I
would get home and my mom would give me
more milk for dinner and along with this
milk I was served a message a message
about calcium about how milk was vital
for strong bones
not the best bone building foods for all
eight bone building calcium that makes a
court a day
Mark turns out that my mom and school
did this because they were lied to for a
very long time and that's what this
video is about the story of milk in this
country shows us how far the government
will go to protect certain industries
even at the expense of telling Americans
the truth about what they're eating it's
a lie that gave us Billboards of Austin
Powers and Stone Cold Steve Austin with
crusty milk mustaches so let me show you
how we at least in America got
brainwashed by milk
it's the only milk I drink
an important food for the health of the
nation
[Music]
okay so before we get into this baby
um I need to thank today's sponsor which
is one I actually use and I'm excited
about co-pilot copilot's a platform that
is designed to make you more consistent
with your workout there's so much focus
on Fitness being about like getting
strong and being faster or whatever for
me it's just like I just need to move my
body every day so I'm not sad it's an
app that goes on your phone and your
watch if you want and it pairs you up
with a coach that you actually speak to
and you tell them what you want to do
how rigorous you want to be what kinds
of things you want to work on whether or
not you have access to weights or a gym
so I met with a coach Devin we had this
conversation about what I want to work
on and then he loaded up like a
personalized training plan for me that I
could start using the next day it's like
frictionless like the technology user
experience is really nice like you just
go through every one of your workouts
there's a visual for every single one of
them and then at the end of your workout
you can give feedback to your trainer
this human element of having a person
that is there and that you're
accountable to that's going to check in
with you changes everything it actually
makes you feel like oh there's someone
who cares about this for accountability
that is really really important so I
love the human element it's not just
like an automated robot it's actually
like a real person who's who's coaching
you and guiding you copilot found that
their clients are nine times more likely
to stick with their goals because of the
way this platform works and I'm not
surprised it's literally meant for
accountability and facilitating a
frictionless experience with moving your
body it's not about getting buffed it's
about just being consistent though you
can get buffed too in the process
there's a link in my description it is
go.myco-pilot.com Johnny Harris if you
click that link you get a free trial
with your own Expert Fitness and health
coach you can see if it works in helping
you move your body and if you're
anything like me that is vital for a
happy life thank you copilot for
supporting this video Let's dive in to
milk
I'm not anti-milk I love milk milk in
fact is pretty magical think about it
milk is the first thing that we drink
when we're born it literally Keeps Us
Alive And if you want to talk about
Evolution and human civilization like
milk was a huge part of this we started
domesticating animals and realized that
the fatty nutritious milk meant for this
baby could also be used for these babies
but human bodies weren't able to digest
milk after childhood they didn't have
the enzymes to do so especially another
animal's milk but the beautiful thing
about human bodies is they can change
over time milk became a key source of
sustenance for people living in certain
parts of the world like northern Europe
they relied on their animals during cold
harsh Winters they couldn't grow crops
same with the nomadic people in like the
Sahara who relied on milk during hot
summers and doing this for a few
thousand years their genes actually
changed suddenly they had enzymes that
could help break down and digest milk
like they forced Evolution to make them
tolerant to milk good for them and that
is why this map exists there's some
weakness to the methodology on how this
map was made but it captures a true
Point here which is that everyone around
the world digests milk differently like
the Bluer your country is in this map
the more people can digest milk so yeah
you've got northern Europe with like 80
or 90 of the population being able to
digest lactose and because of those
nomadic tribes that got used to drinking
milk that's why Niger is blue here
meanwhile in places like Asia most
bodies drink milk and they're like dude
WTF why are you putting baby food in my
adult body we don't digest this after
the age of six get it out of here humans
would find a way around this by taking
the digestive enzyme from a cow's belly
called rennet and mixing it with milk
this would start the breaking down of
the milk and then they could put it in
caves and let it ferment and soon you're
storing your milk and you're also making
it kind of delicious this is the birth
of stuff like cheese and yogurt we also
turned milk into things like butter
which would last longer and is
undeniably one of the most delicious
things that has ever been invented by
humans but raw milk the stuff right out
of the cow's utter wasn't consumed by
anyone besides like kids and frankly
that wasn't the safest thing to do
because milk goes bad really quickly
when it sits around it becomes a cozy
feeding ground for microorganisms which
again was great for making cheese but
kids drinking this stuff was kind of
risky that all changed when this guy
found a way to heat up milk and kill off
all the dangerous pathogens it made it
way safer and way easier to extend the
shelf life he called it pasteurization
which was named after the guy's last
name like am I the only one who thought
the pasteurization came from like the
cow's pasture but it was actually just a
French guy's last name no no one else
thought that I'm literally the only one
who okay
so despite all these problems milk eeks
by from being canceled thanks to
pasteurization and now kids can keep
drinking it okay the evolution and
digestion part of this video is now over
let's get to the economics and the
government policy and now it's the
United States in the 1900s and
technology has given humans new food
options like margarine which threatened
to compete with butter Dairy companies
realized that they needed to defend
their product they needed to prove that
butter was better
so they start doing science this is the
era of dairy science it gets pretty
juicy like this study that shows that
when they gave Dairy to rats they
actually grew stronger and larger and it
must be because of a vitamin inside of
the milk A New Concept let's call it
vitamin A A because it's the first
vitamin we discovered
so yes this is where vitamins came from
like we didn't have vitamins before
1912. and so now Dairy companies are
loving it they have a scientific paper
that says that milk corrects dietary
deficiencies end quote and this is a
little aggressive is the greatest factor
for the protection of mankind that
doesn't sound Sensational or biased in
any way it sounds very scientific
the greatest factor for the protection
of mankind Dairy companies aren't going
to be asleep at the wheel while other
forms of nutrition and fat try to
displace them so they form a cooperation
a council the national Dairy Council
that promotes all things dairy and they
start to build a strong message to the
American people that Dairy isn't just a
nice to have it is scientifically proven
to be vital for your health but like
let's keep some perspective here animal
milk went from being something that
humans couldn't have beyond the age of
six to something that some of us
developed a gene to be able to digest to
then something that was like a hotbed
for pathogens and we solved that with
pasteurization but now in the early
1900s in the United States milk was a
magical perfect white drink that could
cure all things all of this was
happening right in time for a moment
that would change everything both for
the world but also for milk's place in
it it is not an army we must shape for
war it is a nation during World War One
the soldiers were struggling they were
sick were malnourished but lucky for
them the United States was ready with a
perfect product to improve their health
melt we need more milk never enough milk
to go around we were now able to
condense milk into a powder form now it
could last for years on a shelf without
Refrigeration this really helped milk
level up now the magic drink was a magic
powder that could help our men in
uniform fight the bad guys milk was now
associated with patriotism and freedom
and liberty in America man if you want a
way to like make your product popular
and famous just tie it with like America
so now with their big new customer the
United States government Farmers fully
shifted their businesses to Dairy they
needed to meet this demand
but the war ended the men in uniform
came home and these farmers were left
with a massive oversupply of dairy the
government doesn't want to hurt the big
patriotic dairy industry so instead of
telling Dairy Farmers to like go back to
producing less they convinced people to
drink more rich in all the protein
minerals and B vitamins of whole milk
and here's where we really start to see
this vital web of relationships between
Dairy Farmers the United States
government via the Department of
Agriculture scientists and advertisers
it is a web of relationship that cements
milk's place in our culture it is the
reason why in the 90s I was drinking
like five cups of milk a day milk
becomes an advertiser's dream a magic
white liquid that is scientifically
proven to be the key to our children's
health and development and this message
had a very strong Ally at the U.S
department of Agriculture who teams up
with the dairy industry so it's like
after World War One and the USDA gets
involved with these campaigns
the reason I want to show you this stuff
from like the 20s isn't because I want
to give you a history lesson it's
because I want to show you how the US
Department of Agriculture behaved how it
supported the dairy industry how it kind
of pushed a lot of propaganda because
when you see it here in the 20s 100
years ago you'll see the version of
today which I'll show you in a moment
and you'll see those connections and
you'll be like wow not much has changed
and it will kind of blow your mind a
little foreshadow anyway look at this
thing so we have this education milk for
health campaign this is effectively the
government telling the people what they
deem as the healthy thing for everyone
there were milk songs and plays and
posters and this terrifying clown that
told you to brush your teeth and drink
your milk by 1937 kids are supposed to
be drinking one quart of milk a day
luckily from the video I made about the
metric system we've got measuring
vessels around here okay it is 1937 and
the US government wants our children to
drink how much milk
[Music]
I have children and if I ever gave them
this much milk and feel like a criminal
and here's the USDA doing studies to
scientifically prove that this is legit
it's not just advertisers look the
government is doing studies and
Publishing things and now they are
weighing children and measuring them to
show that after this big milk campaign
the kids are taller and way more and
here they are with a bottle of milk and
two graham crackers for lunch like it
truly is becoming the substance for
children and I mean look at this The
Smoking Gun proof of it all one of these
rats had milk and the other didn't these
rats are the same age and each of them
have the same feet except for milk milk
fills a strong and healthy body okay but
this isn't just advertising this is like
real science right it's like South
Dakota State College which is a real
college and the U.S department of
Agriculture cooperating to authoritative
institutions
right well like any science that has
been done you have to look at the
interests here
it turns out that the people doing this
science at South Dakota State College
were receiving a bunch of money from the
state legislature because South Dakota
is a big dairy industry so they fund
this Dairy science program and suddenly
all of these really positive Dairy
studies are coming out that again the
USDA who wants to protect its rural
Farmers is helping support as well
positive science means more Dairy sales
which means supporting local rural
economies which means supporting America
which is so depressing to me yeah I know
this was like in the 20s and 30s but
like this same thing happens today
science that is funded by certain
industries with a certain agenda and it
just sort of muddies everything okay but
what about the economy what happens when
the Great Depression comes and now
Americans can't really afford milk
usually this would hit the dairy
industry and they would have to scale
down because now the demand for milk is
way lower but Farmers weren't going to
let this happen they were becoming like
royalty and so they respond by going on
strike dumping a bunch of milk into the
streets to artificially limit Supply and
drive the price back up and to be like
Fu government where are you at so to fix
this milk's new loyal Ally the US
government steps in and passes a law
that says that if the price of milk dips
below the cost that it takes to produce
it instead of free market economics
where the Dairy Farmers would just make
less of it the government would step in
and cover the cost difference let them
keep making their milk and now the
government is really messing with the
Invisible Hand the market that helps
supply and demand link up with each
other at the right price once you start
doing that it's really hard to go back
so then add in another world war where
even more Farmers got into the milk game
for him and by the 50s milk is cemented
into the American psyche through years
of creative storytelling shaky
scientific messaging war and a
government who was more and more
influenced by Dairy Farmers
the pattern repeats itself in the 70s
the economy is tanking Dairy Farmers are
struggling again and who's here to save
them Jimmy Carter
[Music]
Jimmy did what American leaders before
him did he bowed down before the massive
Dairy Lobby and bailed out Farmers once
again I am in favor of giving farmers
and
a time in the form of two billion
dollars going into the dairy industry to
guarantee them high prices and crucially
for our story to buy the extra milk that
nobody wanted suddenly farmers who were
broke had loads of cash and they were
incentivized to produce as much milk as
possible because they knew the
government would buy it from them okay
but wait what is the government doing
with all this milk milk spoils really
fast okay says Jimmy Carter and company
instead of buying the milk itself let's
also buy a bunch of stuff that uses milk
stuff that can be stored and forgotten
about like butter and powder and cheese
so the Dairy Farmers kept producing tons
of milk and cheese and the government at
one point was buying a quarter of all
cheddar cheese in America but
unsurprisingly when your big customer is
the US government who is buying your
cheese cause America you're not gonna
actually make a great product one woman
who grew up on this stuff wrote about it
in an essay and described it as like
Poor Man's Velveeta government cheese
make the best grilled cheese you'd have
never had in your life and this is
really sad to me because Dairy can be
really cool like I see France with a
tradition of like Brie and like camelbev
and like Holland has gouda and we we've
got this american cheese pasteurized
processed cheese which is kind of more
like a cheese-like substance and isn't a
product of like culture and like
refining a craft it's a product of
modern industrial policies meant to
protect farmers and it's what helped the
United States cement its place as the
home of some of the worst cheese in the
world where do you buy government cheese
you've got to be on a special mailing
list government cheese is also the
special ingredient
so this is how we ended up with a
surplus of horrible cheese sitting in
Limestone caves in Kansas by the 70s
there was 200 million pounds of extra
cheese and other dairy products sitting
here and this is why the government
started giving it away to food banks and
to America's poor the underserved that
wouldn't be buying this cheese in the
first place so they weren't throwing off
the other customers and driving the
price down that's partly because
Americans on welfare were
disproportionately non-white African
Asian or Native American descendants
meaning they're way more likely to be
lactose intolerant see the section above
about evolution in the milk Gene and
stuff this cheese also flowed to schools
and prisons and now we're in the 90s my
childhood where I'm drinking a lot of
milk every day and this is where the
whole government advertising science
thing gets a lot worse in my opinion my
mom just always instilled in me drink
your milk drinking milk is awesome as
having three glasses of milk a day
helped us to really stay lean and fit
the thing about the government getting
involved in setting the price crisis for
stuff is that once you start it's really
hard to go back for some markets that's
okay like insurance and electricity
utilities the government should be
involved but milk like it's just a thing
that people can choose to buy or not
like it should be left to the Invisible
Hand to decide how much people actually
want how much they're willing to pay and
therefore how much firms should produce
but instead the US government had
created a totally distorted Market with
a bunch of fake demand and in the
process incentivizing Farmers to make
tons of milk that nobody wanted and the
problem is with these policies is the
Surplus was just getting bigger and
bigger at one point the government
literally had to start paying Dairy
Farmers to stop producing milk to
slaughter their herds but even that
wasn't working so what's the next
solution well they tried what they did
in the 20s instead of getting the
farmers to produce less let's convince
the people to drink more
so we pass a law that allows all the
Dairy Farmers to pitch into this big
fund that they can use for advertising
and research which are kind of becoming
the same thing and the USDA the
Department of Agriculture becomes like
the referee to make sure that like
they're not only doing any false
advertising and this is where we get
campaigns like this milk it does a body
good and
in the 90s the unforgettable got milk
campaign who shot Alexander Hamilton
milk
they turned got milk into like a cool
thing that every celebrity wanted to be
a part of to the point where they're
taking like way cheaper rates for these
campaigns just because it was like the
cool thing to do this is how you get
this huge variety of different
celebrities all appearing in magazines
and ads for milk not a particular brand
of milk just milk well Mr Miller told me
he never drinks milk
and these cool celebrities are telling
us a story that milk builds strong bones
it has calcium and other essential
nutrients and that it even helps you
lose weight milk your diet lose weight
meanwhile they're funding all of these
studies that are validating their claims
and the USDA standing by just letting it
all happen so this is why in the 90s my
mom had like a bunch of these in her
refrigerator and I can't blame her like
what are you gonna do the government
Authority on nutrition is telling you
that you should be drinking milk you're
seen on all these Billboards and
magazines you have real studies talking
about calcium and bone health this
really embedded itself but if there's
anything we've learned is that no matter
how much these forces push milk on us
people don't actually want to drink as
much milk anymore milk demand even
during the got milk deers started going
down but the dairy lobby wasn't going to
let up they were going to take the hint
from the market so they started finding
other ways to get us to drink milk
instead of drinking it
could eat it
[Music]
so the modern version of this is the
dairy Lobby looking at fast food
restaurants partnering with them to give
us all kinds of cheesy things you can't
see it but in all of these cheesy
advertisements the dairy Lobby is there
lobbying and pushing to get more and
more cheese in these products the dairy
industry literally has its own like
marketing agency called Dairy management
whose goal it is to make this happen
they partner with fast food chains and
they give us stuff like Pizza Hut's
three cheese stuffed crust pizza and the
summer of cheese campaign or personal
favorite Taco Bell's steak quesadilla
that has cheddar pepper jack mozzarella
and cheese sauce that increased Dairy
sales by four percent this one product
that's because it uses eight times more
cheese than any other product on the
menu eight times a tasty Triumph of
culinary engineering bite into the new
steak quesadilla today or Domino's who
has a cheese pizza that has 40 percent
more cheese on it it generates 177
million dollars of sales and the input
for all this cheese a billion additional
pounds of milk but of course we gotta
hit the schools the schools are a
fantastic place to sell Dairy to so
Domino's now gets pizza into 2 000
schools Nationwide and we've got emails
here's an email between Pizza Hut and
the dairy lobbies marketing agency and
they're talking about how to sell more
pizza and more cheese I mean it's
brilliant if you're a marketing person
which is these these people are
advertisers they're like people aren't
drinking milk as much let's just pile it
on to freaking stuffed crust and cheese
Pizzas around America oh and by the way
these people sign their names as Lord of
cheese and Lady of cheese these people
are serious about Dairy the point I'm
making here is these people aren't
nutritionists like they they're not
concerned with anything other than
selling more Dairy I think the former
CEO of this Dairy marketing company is
like if every Pizza included one more
ounce of cheese we would sell an
additional 250 million pounds of cheese
annually just one more Pound Down
Americans throats I mean again I don't
blame these people they're freaking
advertisers they literally only care
about selling stuff what concerns me is
that they're doing this with the
blessing of a government agency who I
pay taxes to it is a powerful All-Seeing
health agency that dictates our
nutritional guidelines and yet they
stand by and support these campaigns for
all of these products that have such
excessive amounts of dairy in them
wait so why does this happen why is the
USDA like on the side of Dairy Farmers
on their website it says that their job
is to promote stuff that will quote
better nourish Americans they put out
things like the food pyramid and they're
supposed to be a source of objective
information about what we should eat but
wait look at this in the same page on
their mission they also say that they
are supposed to quote help Rural America
Thrive and to promote agricultural
production help Americans know how to
nourish themselves and promote Rural
America which one of those things is
more important to them I mean the answer
to that is clear look at the nutritional
guidelines that they put out to be like
here's what you should eat and look at
who advises them on this yeah there's
like some like experts and doctors from
universities but there's also like
Executives from companies like Danon a
yogurt company and a bunch of other
Dairy people who have no other interest
than making money and yet they're like
in the same room as the people who are
deciding what Americans should eat like
no that's not how it works Dairy has
been shoehorned into so much of the
messaging from our government to us over
the years that again of course my mom's
gonna be like yeah you gotta drink milk
the government is telling us that this
is good
[Music]
so yeah the dairy industry is so deeply
embedded in our federal government it's
really hard to turn it back this
unnatural false demand that we have in
our country for dairy is really hard to
like rewind and the amount of money that
flows to influential lawmakers to keep
this whole thing going
so you can't really cut it off but some
of you were thinking like we're not
talking about cigarettes like this is
milk it's not a bad thing like calcium
is good for your bones right
no I mean yes but no yes calcium is good
for your bones milk has things that help
you but like you can get all of that
stuff from other places there's nothing
special about this white substance
unless you're like a farmer in Sweden in
1532 and it's winter and you can't have
crops like with less than a cup of
almonds you get that much calcium dried
figs some cooked kale even tofu which
comes from soybeans you can get this
stuff from a bunch of different foods
and a reminder that five billion people
more than half the world don't drink
milk like they're fine and there are
even studies now showing that too much
milk can actually be bad for your bones
so no despite all the industry-funded
studies that tell us that milk is the
magical Elixir and all of the creative
storytelling that's embedded in our
psyche this is not some magic substance
this is a thing that was meant for cow
babies but the fact remains that I still
consume a lot of dairy that's because
milk is a magical beautiful thing it's
delicious it has a deep history for so
many cultures around the world and even
here in the United States there are a
bunch of Dairy Farmers who are small
respectable family-owned Farms who have
been doing this for a really long time
making really amazing products that go
to actually meet a real demand for
people who actually want to eat
delicious cheese or milk or whatever I'm
not saying let's get rid of it Dairy is
freaking delicious but the dairy
industry we have does not celebrate that
does not create a market around
beautiful products and things that
people want it is a fake Market that has
been pushed to us through Real Lies
through this idea that milk is essential
with things that you can't get anywhere
else A Century of the most clever
marketing
good
I guess what I feel here is like a
little bit disillusioned that the
government agencies that we pay our
taxes to to give us objective advice and
guidance can sometimes lead us astray be
so deeply under the influences of
Corporations and old Legacy Industries
in our country that they end up
protecting them more than they protect
us that is disappointing to me
[Music]
thank you foreign
thanks for watching
um thanks again to co-pilot for
sponsoring the video that link in the
description helps support this Channel
and also get you a free trial with your
own Expert Fitness and health coach and
thank you all for watching a video about
milk
um do I do food things now is that like
is that one of my Beats is like food
Doritos and breakfast and yeah I guess
it is
I'm a food guy we're off to a new year
and we are making a lot of cool things
and I am really grateful for all of you
being here I'm grateful for those over
at The Newsroom who are supporting um
it's our patreon where you get an extra
video every month access to my scripts
access to Tom Fox royalty free music
that you can use in your own videos and
you are supporting our operation here as
we try to make good journalism on the
internet we also have Luts and presets
which we sell so you can color your
videos and photos I'm publishing all of
my videos a week early over on nebula
because that's a thing that we do now
see the link in the description for that
and uh generally we're just being
curious about the world and trying to
make cool stories so
um thank you all for being here and for
your comments and your thoughts and your
feedback it is very very helpful and I
will see you soon in the next video bye
everyone
foreign